à partir de ce lundi se déroulera à
paris le procès en appel du bs cette
banque suisse lourdement condamnés en
2019 par la justice française une amende
record dans une affaire d'évasion
fiscale
3,7 milliards d'euros à laquelle on
ajoute 800 millions de dommages et
intérêts pour l'état français
cinq ex cadres et dirigeants du groupe
ont été condamnés à des peines allant de
6 à 18 mois de prison avec sursis
les enquêteurs avaient mis la main sur
38 mille comptes offshore de citoyens
hexagonaux pour représentant un montant
de 12 milliards d'euros à l'époque des
comptes du footballeur bixente lizarazu
de l'actrice valeria bruni tedeschi de
la créatrice sonia rykiel ou encore de
l'entraîneur de football guy roux avait
été identifié tous ont depuis
régulariser leur situation
la banque privée suisse a donc été
sanctionné en février 2019 pour
démarchage bancaire illégal et
blanchiment aggravé de fraude fiscale
des fautes pénales d'une exceptionnelle
gravité selon la présidente de la 32ème
chambre correctionnelle christine mais
les ténors du barreau hervé temime et
denis chemla défend des la banque
helvétique
ils ont aussitôt contesté le jugement
estimant qu'il n'était étayé par aucune
preuve concrète dans un communiqué la
plus grande banque privée du monde a
expliqué avoir respecté et appliqué les
dispositions légales suisses et
françaises
elle a donc fait appel face à cette
défense le parquet national financier
avait dénoncé le festival d'hypocrisie
de la part de l'établissement suisse
pour les mêmes accusations
elle s'était acquitté d'amandes de 780
millions de dollars aux états unis et de
300 millions d'euros en allemagne afin
d'éviter un procès alors en quoi
consistait cette fraude alléguée
la justice reproche à ubs d'avoir envoyé
des chargés d'affaires helvétiques sur
le sol français des marchés de riches
clients lors d'événements mondains
organisés par la banque mais ne
disposait pas de la licence pour le
faire ces transactions étaient inscrits
manuellement dans des cahiers dits
carnets du lait afin de partager les
commissions entre français et suisses
ainsi échapper selon l'accusation à la
régulation
ceci constituerait un système de
blanchiment généralise
de l'hexagone vers la suisse second
grief seuls 1 à 2% des français en
question ont déclaré ces fonds alors
qu'ils doivent en principe
impérativement le faire
ubs est en outre accusé d'avoir incité
ses clients français à diriger leurs
fonds sur des comptes offshore des
contrats d'assurance-vie couvert à
l'époque par le secret bancaire suisse
pour les faire échapper à la fiscalité
française
pour sa défense ubs assure avoir prélevé
restituer un impôt sur ses comptes à la
france l'existence d'une telle fraude a
été révélée à la justice grâce à cinq
anciens employés du bep est révolté par
les transactions dont il était témoin
l'une des lanceurs d'alert stéphane
djibo ancien responsable des relations
publiques du ps avait été sommé par la
banque un moment critique d'effacer les
données de son ordinateur
elle a refusé et décidé de confier ces
informations aux enquêteurs français
licenciée elle a reçu des lettres
d'insultés a été cambriolée c quinn et
en frais d'avocats et en pure perte pour
elle elle n'aura pas eu droit à un
centime de l'état pour ses bons et
loyaux services
en comparaison bradley birkenfeld
banquier de boston et lanceurs d'alert à
toucher 104 millions de dollars du
bureau des lanceurs d'alerté américain
pour ses révélations sur ubs
comme quoi faire sauter la banque n'est
pas toujours synonyme de butin alors que
va donner ce combat de titans entre le
fisc français le secret bancaire suisse
à l'heure des révélations sur le
luxembourg paradis fiscal prospère au
sein de l'union européenne
délibéré vaudra son pesant d'or